yo what's going on guys Rob I know I
haven't made a video in forever and you
know that you're overdue for a tutorial
when someone asks you or you did on your
channel because I haven't uploaded a
video on almost two months so I figured
I would give you guys a little info
about what's going on with me in school
what I've been doing recently
and what a usual day for me is like so
the first thing I do when I wake up is
actually feed my cat so she's around
here somewhere Lila Lila come on so she
wants to eat all right so this is Lila's
breakfast all right little you're gonna
show them Syd she's already sitting I
didn't even have to say anything look at
that wooden cat good girl
okay that's enough of that I got to get
off to school so I'm gonna get my
backpack my jacket and I'm gonna head
out one thing I don't like to do is to
push elevator buttons with my finger so
I always push it with my knuckle you
don't know how dirty elevator buttons
are people never clean those I know I'm
sounding like I'm a germaphobe I'm
really not but I don't like to touch
elevator buttons for a reason all right
guys I am headed on my way to class it
is 7:30 for so I'm actually headed on my
way to restorative dentistry - we just
got our drills this semester so we've
been practicing for the last month or
two learning how to drill on fake teeth
and how to fill it with amalgam which is
basically like that silver colors
filling and that's what we've been doing
for the last a few months practicing how
to drill different types of preparations
it's called the preparation when you
when you prepare tooth for a filling or
um other types of restorations that you
can fix the teeth with so I'm at a red
light and that uh triggers a red light
challenge you guys never seen Cash Cab
no no you just think I'm acting strange
cuz I am if you can't tell already this
is the first time that I've ever tried
to film myself while I'm driving I think
people are looking at me like I'm insane
why is that guy holding a camera to
himself while he's driving what a weirdo
oh yeah well they don't know we
obviously do they ha ha ha
dear some lab right now these things you
see on my head or you called Moops and
they're kind of like binoculars and I
also have a little bit of a have a
little light here that allows me to kind
of shine onto the tooth to allow me to
see a little better so what I've been
doing now I've been drilling on some of
the fake teeth and the type of dot that
I showed you in the other video and then
we're filling it with the amalgam which
is like the silver filling that you
might get when you go to a dentist and I
also have my drill set up over here this
is a high-speed drill and it shoots out
water to kind of cool down the tooth
when you're drilling on it and you also
have a slow-speed drill
it's hot the truffle
I can jump
so what I just did I'm drilling on the
maxillary tooth here number eleven and
that's called a class three preparation
alright so once you have a hole in the
tooth that you prepared then you need to
fill it with amalgam so what we do is we
take these little capsules and you run
over to the trader which basically mixes
the mountain
good morning people
hey um someone left their Explorer and
then you're ready to pack it so all you
got to do is to open that up I guess and
there you go there's your filling
material so what you do now is you
actually fill up this little amalgam
carrier with the amalgam by pushing down
on it and that picks it up in the end
there and then you could place it inside
the preparation that you did
and then you use these condensers to
condense it into that little hole
and then you keep putting more and more
so there I have one layer of amalgam and
I'm going to keep on filling that until
it fills the entire hole that I have
there for the tooth all right hi so
that's a pretty typical day for me at
school wake up in the morning going off
to class doing some lab work or going to
anatomy
I had anatomy later on that day but I'm
not allowed to bring the camera and I'm
sure a lot of you probably wouldn't want
to see what goes on in that anyway but
as of now I'd like to give you guys a
little bit of an update I am off for
spring break and I'm back home so I hope
you know what get means Hey
yeah so besides getting some extra sleep
and having my cat's butt in my face I
definitely like to get some new videos
out this week as of today I just broke
17,000 subscribers so I like to thank
all you guys for subscribing commenting
rating I really appreciate everything
but I definitely feel like I have an
obligation I need to release more videos
you know for you guys even if I'm in
school you know just taking the time out
to make like a 2 or 3 minute video
letting you guys know what's going on
I'm probably going to be going on blogtv
really soon within the next day or two
I'd say to get even some live feedback
to see what you guys would really like
to see I know right now I have mostly
Rubik's cubes and origami on my channel
but I'm going to be switching it up in
the future I'm going to be putting
tutorials for other things being that
it's a beautiful day outside and then I
found my old skateboard from like 12
years ago I figured I would make a fool
out of myself on camera and try to do
some tricks so leave me a comment below
let me know what you guys think of the
video I hope you enjoyed it and I'll be
sure to see you guys soon on blogtv
all right well I guess that was better
than crossing my butt so see you guys
later